morning the prime minister boris johnson
is promising that more than 23 million
people will be able to book a booster
jab by the end of january it's a massive
expansion of the vaccine program and the
government is appealing for thousands of
volunteers to help the nhs temporary
vaccine sites will be set up around the
country and around 400 military
personnel will assist the rollout but if
mr johnson had another message it was
that christmas is safe and there is
still time to party the health secretary
sanji javid is with us lots to get
through let's talk good morning to you
uh let's start first of all with um our
viewers
sense of exhaustion this morning that we
have to deal with another twist and turn
in this covid um challenge um how are
you coping with it all
well there's a there's a lot of work to
be done and i just have to start by
thanking all the people in the nhs
especially in social care for
you know think of the the two years that
they've had the most challenging time i
think they'd say in living memory for
anyone uh working in in in care and
health and now you know this variant
comes along and it's uh
we've we have to still ask more of them
i know they're up to it but it's a big
ask and i just want to stand by start by
thanking them and i mean with this
variant we
we are you know we we're trying to learn
and assess more about it and in the
meantime in the next few weeks we want
to build our defenses and our best form
of defense still remains our vaccines
it's possible of course it's possible
that it might be less effective we just
don't know for sure yet but it's also
very likely that they'll remain
effective against serious disease and
that's why we made the announcement
around the booster program yesterday
i asked the jcvi that's our group of
independent advisors on vaccines whether
it would now make sense in life this
variant to really expand the program
it's already really successful but to
really properly expand it and they came
back and said we should do just that by
dosing
so
halving the dosing interval and also by
expanding it to all adults and it's a
real national mission i would say for
all of us we've all got a role to play
on this and and if any of your viewers
if they if they get the call from the
nhs then please do i would just say to
them please do you know step up roll up
your sleeves and protect yourselves
23 million booster vaccines to be slated
by the end of january though that's a
tough ask isn't it that's what half a
million a day
it's it's a huge ask and uh
it's something i i do believe that the
all the people working in the nhs all
the volunteers they are up to it but it
is it of course is a huge ask and that's
why i call it a national mission this
has become from a health point of view
the most important thing that we can do
to protect ourselves to protect the
progress uh that we've made but i know
that the nhs uh are up to it in the last
week before sort of omicron um was a
thing uh we i think we delivered about
2.4 million uh vaccinations across the
uk and that's obviously that's that's
huge we need to now increase that by
around a million a week but i think it
can be done to give everyone an offer by
january but it's really important that
people take up that offer because that's
what's going to protect us let's count
us through lots to talk about the pm
says the new rules will be assessed
after three weeks what criteria would
you use
the
key thing will be the assessment of our
scientists
of the variant now what we need to
determine
is it you're any more dangerous than the
delta variant and as i say we don't know
the answers to that we've seen in the
last few days a number of scientists
whether from here from south africa i
spoke to my counterpart in south africa
yesterday and let me also just say i
think the way south africa has behaved
is is exemplary in in being open and
transparent about what it discovered but
in in talking to other scientists we
don't know enough about it yet but that
will be the key thing is to determine uh
if it is any more dangerous than the
current dominant variant the delta
variance three weeks is an arbitrary
figure isn't it really because it could
take longer than that for us to know
whether people have got it and then find
themselves in hospital we won't know
within three weeks just the challenge
that we're facing with this well um i
wouldn't call it an arbitrary figure i
think where you might be a bit right is
that
you know it might it yeah only a bit is
that it might take a bit longer than
three weeks it might be a bit sooner
than three weeks of december as opposed
to 25th you know but see where i'm going
with that yeah no of course and that's
why we we're confident that actually
maybe within two weeks that we can know
a lot more about this we might not even
need to wait three weeks but the three
weeks was i think a a sort of
a sensible date to set for a review
because
now that we have live samples of the of
the virus they've gone to our labs in
important down our scientists some and
the best scientists in the world are
working through it we're working with
our g7 colleagues i held a meeting with
g7 health ministers on monday as well to
discuss this and so we're working
internationally we're working at pace at
home and i think in a couple of weeks we
will know a lot more about this variant
between now and then the prime minister
said we should be attending christmas
parties um the um the chief advisor
saying we shouldn't where are you
well i think people should continue to
behave in the way that they were
planning to behave over christmas i
don't think there's any need to change
those plans the only changes that have
been made in the last few days are the
ones that everyone now i think knows
about about it might affect your
international travel plan so if someone
had plans to travel over christmas
then there could be an impact there of
course uh there's the need to
self-isolate if you come into contact
with someone uh with uh omicron yeah are
you worried about a pig
no no i'm not um the case numbers are
well at this point in time the case
numbers are are very low i think
throughout the uk we've got 22 confirmed
cases at the moment and that will go up
it will certainly uh go up but the
numbers are low i hope it sort of stays
that way so i'm not worried about the
sort of pandemic type situation but
we've always also said that even before
we knew about the variant in our sort of
plan a we've always been clear that
as you get into
deeper winter the colder darker days the
virus likes that not just this virus the
flu virus they all they like that and so
you know as we do that then your people
should just be you know careful to to
try and think can they ventilate a room
and just follow the current guidance
let's crack on um should people take a
test uh cover test before they go to a
christmas party
i would i would it's not a formal
recommendation the guidance but if i was
going to a party with lots of people and
things i would but i would have done
that by the way even before we knew
about this variant again the reason i
would have done that is because it's
getting colder it's getting darker we're
spending more time indoors probably more
people indoors than before just because
of the colder darker days so are
sensible precautions that everyone can
take you're talking about overseas
travel labor saying that there should be
pre-departure tests from the country
that you are in before you come into the
uk why don't we do that we used to do it
we did used to do it and we got rid of
it because we didn't think we needed it
anymore when the variant came along and
with what little we do know about it we
had to
it was right to take some
measures around travel and the most
important one we actually took is the
red listing so you know the moment i
learned about this virus and and the
potential threat of it within hours we
redlisted six countries in southern
africa we've added four more we're the
first in the world uh to do that and
then also we've put in this measure
around if you come in from anywhere in
the world that you will have to take a
pcr test by day two and uh only could
already be
is it under review the two the
pre-departure testing we keep all these
rules under review i don't anticipate
any change from what we've announced
just in the last few days but of course
we always keep it in review should the
situation change then we would have to
look at that again but i don't really
anticipate any change for now the world
health organization yesterday said over
60 shouldn't travel overseas what do you
think
the the the world health organization is
taking this very seriously which is
really important and uh we are working
uh with them uh it's understandable
they're concerned about them
no i i would just say
again we just stick to what we already
know right even there's a lot we don't
know about the very well
what we know is that the older you are
the more you're vulnerable you are to
this virus
and there are ways to sensibly protect
yourself
so if you ask if it was my mother you
know um i would say to her you know
she's got her booster shot so that's
great if she really wanted to travel you
wear a mask on the plane and things like
that but i don't think you she should be
worried about traveling so that would be
my advice um you talked about south
african scientists and how much praise
they needed again talking about the
world health organization yesterday they
said um that because of what we did and
the fact that we put them and the other
countries on the red list that
disincentivizes countries to report and
share epidemiological and sequencing
data do you agree
well i think i think they there's a
there's a point about
making sure that those countries that
come forward and share the information
like south africa did like the uk did
when we had the alpha very you'll
remember that and uh and we were very
open with the rest of the world just in
the same way south africa is and that's
the right thing to do it's a much poorer
country than us and they rely much more
on tourism and they're being penalized
i wouldn't say they're being penalized i
i agree with everything else you just
said about south africa but it is really
important that the rich countries that
they recognize that south africa has
come forward done the right thing and
offers it whatever support it needs so
on the the call that i organize with g7
health ministers on monday we talked
about this we we it was in our final
statement about praising south africa
and offering even more support than
otherwise and yesterday it's one of the
reasons i had a call with the south
african health minister to offer our
support so you don't agree with the
world health organizations that it
disincentivizes countries
you put them on the red list
no i think it's it's important that
countries come forward but there are
other ways to support them okay can we
talk about nhs waiting times please if
we may national audit office report uh
estimating that if 50
of those that have missed their
referrals during the pandemic come
forward then the waiting list would
reach 12 million by march 2025.
in fact i think i've previously been on
your program and said it could reach 13
million for precisely the same reason
and uh and by the way i do want people
this fact is in the money that you've
already that you hope to raise as well
though doesn't it from the national
insurance contributions the rise um
well i
i don't know if it does apparently but
but yeah i don't know and even if it did
i don't think they would at this point
know about all the plans that we've got
to to you know get through the waiting
list much faster than otherwise because
of all the new funding that's coming but
that said
the the waiting list
will rise before it falls it will rise
for two reasons first is that a lot of
people that didn't come forward are
coming forward and again i want them to
come forward i hope it's more than 50
percent even that's more work for the
nhs i don't want anyone to think that
they have to stay away from the nhs and
secondly we've got a lot of the demand
in any case even before the delay demand
there's there's there's all those sort
of usual demand that would be there now
that said the work that we're doing on
especially on elective procedures and
diagnostics with the new community
diagnostic centers with the surgical
hubs you know this is all going to make
a big difference as well
by this time next year
it i think we'll be getting through a
lot more procedures on a daily basis
than this time last year
and that's going to be helping a lot of
people will it be better by this time
next week will be better because we'll
be getting through a lot more procedures
okay um let's talk about the social care
plan because we're almost out of time uh
we're going to get the white paper i
always think so um the white paper later
on today um will it be clearer by then
how many people will have to sell their
homes
the white paper that's coming out today
is um
it's less about the the new means
testing system which is really generally
where the detail was didn't we well no
this this white paper i i don't want to
there's a there's a couple of white
papers that are planned for adult social
care and what the white paper today is
about is there's in the spending review
there was uh over five billion pounds
allocated to adult social care of that
uh just under two billion pounds and one
point seven billion pounds is for what's
called a a
it's funding for the adult social care
system improvements to the whole system
so this is about spending on the
workforce on on training on uh
occupational therapy and support people
have to sell their homes well you you
will know today is about how we're going
to support adult social care much more
when it comes to the question you just
asked me about selling homes and not
what we already know you don't have to
wait for that is that we've already set
out plans that means that billions more
a year will be going in to support
people with adult social care costs with
the most generous means testing system
this country has ever seen for adult
social care and with everyone's cost of
care being capped at eighty six thousand
we need another fifteen minutes on that
don't we so i'm sure you'll come back
and talk to us about it in more detail
in the meantime what are you doing for
christmas
i'm spending it with my family in
brumsgrove okay just a small group or a
big party just my family there we go
it's good to talk to you thank you very
much indeed it's always a pleasure thank
you